the Obama team well they're both make it
harder and harder to do that every day
aren't they you know if Hillary says
Obama's not prepared to answer the phone
at 3am then she really shouldn't make
him our vice president because should
something happen to her then who's going
to answer the phone at 3am you know not
him and I think you know from his side I
think you know what did his foreign
policy advisors say yesterday she's a
monster or something like that Samantha
power although she's apologized now but
you know I just think there's a level of
animosity there that would make it make
it tough for them to to not only run as
a ticket but to put to work together and
I you know I can't sort of see Hillary
Clinton or Barack Obama as the type of
vice president who sort of fades away
you know that's not what vice presidents
do anymore ever since Al Gore was vice
president they've had a real role I mean
Janie is believed by many to be actually
be running things so you know that's I
would be very surprised by that but i
should say there's a tremendous amount
of pressure for that solution growing
within the party lots of people want
that and and i think would find it hard
to accept that that either of these
candidates would would decline that
offer when in a lot of ways it would be
a very powerful ticket I think it'd be
hard if they could do it it would be
hard to beat them
there are a lot of names floating around
the rest you know you hear people like
you hear the names of people who have
supported either of them who have given
them sort of critical support so you
hear odd names I've heard people mention
that former Senate Majority Leader Tom
Daschle who is a bomber supporter would
be a potential vice presidential nominee
I don't think he could win his home
state but you know they-they-they he's
mentioned people for a while we're
mentioning the governor of Iowa Tom
Vilsack as a vice president for Hillary
but you know Iowa was a long time ago
and didn't go that well and I don't
think she's going to pick him then
they've mentioned Ohio the Governor of
Ohio Ted Strickland and that went better
and it they certainly need to win Ohio
in the fall but I'd be surprised if if
she chose him to the person I think they
ought to take a hard look at both of
them is is general Anthony's any the
former Central Command a commander who
is has what I would say outstanding
military and diplomatic experience and
it's been a strong critic of the Bush
administration someone like that anyway
from from the Democratic side if you're
running against John McCain you need to
sort of bolster the military security
credentials of either of these
candidates and I think picking someone
like that or Wes Clark former NATO
supreme commander wes clark who is a
strong Democrat and has been a supporter
of Hillary Clinton would be another good
choice
you